After a tough year that saw U.S. car sales at 26-year lows,...
...industry experts say, automakers are turning the corner.
And in 2010, Magazine Editor Richard Headland says, the buzzword is "green".
The emerging trend in 2010 is gonna be a continued move towards environmentally friendly cars.
So, the big focus right now is on miles per gallon and CO2,...
...and if you go to all the big car shows now, they're the words that dominate.
Analysts say, improving access to credit and a return to 3% growth in the global economy...
...will help car manufacturers recapture some of the ground lost in 2009.
To do that, automakers are re-designing to make new models more attractive to young and old.
For younger buyers, Toyota's Hi-CT gets its inspiration from popular Japanese anime characters.
And car makers are also seeing great potential in upscale markets.
I think we're gonna see with the luxury car market is more and more luxury hybrids.
So Lexus, for example, already has several luxury hybrids.
BMW is working on its first luxury hybrids, Mercedes as well.
Automakers are also hoping to snap consumers out of their recessionary mood by using brighter colors.
Octavio Navarro is a spokesman for the Ford Motor Company.
Everybody has vibrant colors, you know.
Typically, it'd be black or gray...
...but you're really starting to see bright yellows or bright blues.
Ford in particular, one of the things we are introducing this year is the 2011 Fiesta...
...and one of my favorite colors for it is called "Lime Squeeze".